here's what you have to understand about
the ultra wealthy versus the masses the
masses want to get rich so they can own
the lambo so they can own the yacht the
Mansion the private jets they want to
show it off they want to flaunt their
wealth but owning stuff is for the
peasants when you legally own something
leeches want to sue you every chance
they get these want to steal from you
the government wants to tax you into
Oblivion ambitious prosecutors want to
take you down and the plebs want to
pillage you that is why the ultra
wealthy do not want to own stuff because
owning stuff sucks instead what you want
to do is have control over your assets
as if you owned it without actually
owning it you want to live in the
penthouse on Billionaire's row without
it being tied to your name you want to
sell your mega yell without it being
under your name just ask the Russian
oligars if they agree the key is control
not ownership you want to be able to do
everything you can with the thing as if
you owned it without having your name on
the papers